yeah it's weird man but i think kids
growing up on on a budget like having
like
realizing how hard you work yeah and
like trying to make ends meet
so much better than then we kind of you
know what my kids are dealing with where
they don't realize like
amazon oh i want this toy it shows up in
the grow up with money no
so that's so we go to chili's and you
know i was a fat
kid and i love the full rack of ribs and
the chocolate shake
i knew my mom was paid if she didn't
have a problem with it
if we'd sit down and go i'm getting the
ribs and the shake which you know at
chili especially back then it's like
jesus christ
dude my mom's like no you're not we're
going it's chicken fingers and you and
your brother's splitting it
and i'm like oh mom didn't get paid yeah
i could tell when we didn't have money
too
um and it's it's triggering for me now
like if someone talks about money or
being broke it's super triggering
like shoes too like i remember we were
at uh
it must have been like a ross or
something they had these these ear walks
and me and my brother one we were
begging my mom crying she's like i don't
have the money yeah
i feel so bad about it now because we're
begging my mom by the shoe she's like i
literally
don't have the money can you imagine so
now that you're a parent i remember
saying that
to my kids it's so
at the same time when you're older now
as i'm older i look back and i go i'm
glad they had that experience
i'm glad that they know that things
aren't free and everything doesn't come
easy
but at the time as a parent i can't
imagine one of the most
dude i will tell you one of the hardest
five minutes of my life
i was on something called wic which is
basically a food program here in
california where you can get
like food stamps if you have young kids
you can get
uh formula and things like that right
so i had my wic stuff and um
i was at ralph's and man it was i used
to go
to ralph's during off hours so there
weren't that many people there or maybe
i didn't see somebody i knew
and there was a woman behind me and she
was just trying to be nice and she was
like let me pay for that for you
[ __ ] it was the i i i was like no
i said it's hard enough for me to do
this yeah i can't have a stranger
i know do you know what i mean like and
i would by the way if i'm her i offer
the same thing
without realizing how it makes that
other person feel i've done the same
thing where i offered
i saw this mom with a kid i could i
could just tell the kid looked dirty the
mom to have all this [ __ ] together
and i was like let me up and i i
i [ __ ] up because i you know i in my
hand like i'll pay for her stuff
it's gonna give her a huge break and i
bet she can save the money do something
else with it
and she's like growing up you know the
food's going through i'm like oh you
know what just
i'll cover hers just charge that and
charge mine shoes no no no thanks
it's hard and i was like what a dick and
i say i'm like oh
it's an ego thing it's less it's so much
like an ego like pride pride
because at the end of the day man i
still want to feel
like i i mean like a man isn't the right
word but i still want to feel like
provider yeah like like and now i can't
even do
that i know dude and it was it was
really there was a lot of
real at the time this is gonna sound
real weird at the time
i was like i can't wait i hope this is
over
i'll do anything to get out of this
situation but i look back
and i think i'm so glad i went through
that yeah i bet i really am so glad i
went through that and
no having kids now and dealing with what
i deal with and then my i remember my
mom
she would be like we're starving mama we
we didn't have food
we're like we're starving she write a
check and it would bounce
yeah to feed us yeah dude i i will get
when i start talking about this too i
try
it's hard it's heartbreaking and i think
about it and it's heartbreaking to know
that there are people all around
who are hitting that right now dude and
i i can only tell you from my experience
from doing that
you know there were i would sometimes
look at the week and go okay
the first two days of this week are
gonna be one meal days for me
i'm doing one meal the kids are gonna
yeah i'm gonna break that one meal into
three for them yup but i'm gonna eat
lunch
right and to have to navigate that
and i i was so conf i'm so concerned
about
the kids right and so i remember i
talked to my dad and my dad was like
they'll only know
you're poor if you let them know if you
let them know that this is a shitty city
you're poor
yeah yeah he said now when they get
older they go to school especially in
l.a
but as a young person he said
tell me what what is at the time jacob
was like too he's like what is jacob's
favorite
toy i'm like honestly if you gave him an
empty refrigerator box and two balloons
it's on that's it yeah and he was like
just remember that i don't know it's not
the amount of when you go to these big
parties and they're
they have ponies for their kids and
birth the truth of the matter is
the kids would have just as much fun at
a certain age doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
yeah i remember my dad that's why i'm so
into broncos he had this bronco that he
bought worked his my dad worked his
[ __ ] tail off he was like supe
pursuit of happening to go door-to-door
shout out and [ __ ] they had this broncos
used was a two-door bronco
and it was tan and i remember he had his
brother
worked in cars and he had the decals put
on so it looked like an eddie bauer
version they put the eddie bauer seats
in it
and i thought it was the i was like
we're
so rich so i'm like papa drop me off at
school and i'd get out like what's up
and yeah
what's up listen dude like dude is that
a
two-door ford bronco yeah it is
i do have pictures of me watching it i
used to watch it all the time but what
so when
the new broncos coming out i i was like
dude can i get it in tan because i'm
gonna i want to do the same thing
that's super cool like we don't offer
tanned dumbass like that makes sense
yeah
why would you yeah but i could do it i
could have someone do it when my
when we were growing up this is when i
thought my dad ended up with money
we went from no car we had to borrow a
car to go shopping
and our neighbor who we borrowed the car
from get ready for this dick move
was like sure you can borrow the car to
go shopping but your kids
have to clean my house oh god what a
come on bro come right what a dick move
okay
but i will tell you by the way that you
know what the trigger for me is
because when i could tell when my
parents had a little bit of money
because
the potato chips in the cabinet didn't
just say potato chips
you know we used to go to this place
called price chopper yeah and price
chopper
it would just say beer and you know what
i mean potatoes
like we used to get we didn't get mac
and cheese it was a black
and white box and say macaroni and
cheese
dinner yeah this looks
bootleg where's like the cool dragon in
blue and yellow
yeah where's nemo
there's none of that dude i remember
when my camera could help her when my
dad got a job
and we got ready for this we thought we
were fancy we got a brand new honda
accord
maroon oh no maybe burgundy burgundy but
when you're a kid it's like new car
might as well be a lamborghini come on
it's a new car honda accord
was it strange fresh but you're kids now
i'm sure they appreciate it more than
ever
right like jacob's like hustling right
jacob is hustling man he's out on the
road right now on an amazon prime show
um as a pa but he's traveling to all the
national parks you know my oldest son is
in the army yep
and my daughter is a vet assist yo my
daughter ready for this
my daughter used to live deep in the
valley so off a white oak
she had an internship unpaid internship
in santa monica at a vet she had to take
two buses that took two hours
there and two hours back she used to get
her to a non-paid
internship because without going to
school that was the only place
in the field that she wanted to give her
a chance yeah
and i and that hustle
nut right there a lot of people we know
are grown people who are like nah i'm
not doing oh hell no
so like there are certain things that i
feel like
they i truly believe kids learn more
from
watching us than some
don't you think like my dad wasn't a
verbal dude
but i learned from watching i agree when
i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son